and joining me in the studio for more on
the mysteries of the comet is a
planetary researcher from the German
Aerospace Center kallmann also always
very nice to have you on the show so
we've seen just so a lot of information
and in the last six months that the
Rosetta probe has been orbiting the
comet there's been there's been
discovery after discovery which of those
discoveries do you personally think is
most astonishing most astonishing and
most exciting are of course the dunes we
see on the surface so that's an airless
body so no atmosphere we don't expect to
have been sir but we see material moving
across the surface the second thing is
causing it what's causing it we really
we think that the the sublimation of the
icy material of the interior is causing
some kind of mobility some kind of wind
on the surface but that was not expected
so far so there should be a connection
between the outgassing of the body when
it comes closer to the Sun and the
formation of transported material on the
surface and obviously third support of
material of a over surface build
students I'm just curious we always
heard in the run-up to to to this
mission we heard about comets they were
always described as sort of huge dirty
ice balls we haven't really found water
we haven't found ice why not because
it's in the interior so and obviously
the ice will supply them from the
surface immediately so the material left
on the surface is the silly cat occur or
the rocky part of the comet so that
means the surface is covered that I
don't know how much a few meters a few
tens of meters of fluffy dirty material
the comet is plunging down towards the
Sun we're going to be following it for
about another six months what can we
expect to happen oh there are many
things which we expect to happen the
first is we will see more and more and
more activity so we really get
a more material coming out from the
interior and that's not only that's not
only the vapor of water ice but there
must be a lot of other things coming out
with this which are carbon which are
carbon compounds and a number of na
routine and what whatever it is they're
so we probably see some kind of chemical
reactions in there and we see the body
getting smaller just just a quick look
at the near future than m space research
you the you know the European Space
Agency has a lot of different projects
and missions on the books what can we
expect to see in the next months and
years we still have missions at Mars
there are new missions planned on Mars
there's a robo blend on north which
should grilled for the first time and go
in the subsurface and and get a better
sample of the subsurface probably
bringing us closer to the question
whether there is life or not and is also
planning to have a mission which really
can look very deep in space for
extrasolar planets and also a mission
which is going back to the Jovian system
exploring the moon Ganymede and Europa
which we expect have an ocean under
their ice crust so there's a number of
things going on with eiza what's going
on prof your men thanks very much for
joining us here on tomorrow today okay
thank you